incompetent clumsy inept insecure
dysfunctional not exactly how you'd
expect to be described by your best
friend but that's exactly what our
ambassador to the United States thinks
of Donald Trump and his administration
so Kevin Derrick's scathing assessment
of the president was leaked to the mail
on Sunday the cache of diplomatic memos
dating back to 2017 suggests that
communication with the president needs
to be kept simple even blunt so Kim goes
on to say we don't really believe this
administration is going to become
substantially more normal less
dysfunctional less unpredictable less
faction driven less diplomatically
clumsy and inept but some Tory MPs
aren't impressed with Sir Kim's lack of
diplomacy I think the thing with
diplomatic cables and I used to work at
the Foreign Office I'd be quite careful
about what you say which is on a
personal basis in those cables because
it's all very well talking about the
substance of the relationship the
policies but I think some of that may in
retrospect be regarded as unwise but at
the end of the day I'm sure that the two
sides will get beyond any any of those
kind of college following brexit the UK
will look to increased trading
opportunities with the United States one
of the reasons the president was
afforded a full state visit in June this
year
but so Kim warns that although mr. Trump
was dazzled by all the pomp and ceremony
his administration would remain the land
of America first the motivation behind
the league isn't known and nor as a
source and that breach in security will
cause some concern I think that the main
concern frankly within the British
government will be how this was leaked
because you know this transcends
personalities if your ambassador at your
most important ally cannot in a secure
way communicate his thoughts back to
London back to the prime minister back
to the Foreign Secretary then there has
to be an investigation and a way of
improving the security around these
communications the Foreign Office has
defended sukham saying we pay our
diplomats to be candid in a statement it
said the British public would expect our
ambassadors to provide ministers with an
honest unvarnished assessment of the
politics in their country there's been
no reaction yet from the president but
it will come and how will he react well
it's hard to say one description sir Kim
might have added about Donald Trump is
his unpredictability Ashish Joshi Sky
News